when apple first revealed the m1 macbook
air a little over a year ago we had no
idea how much it would impact the laptop
space with the impressive combination of
build quality performance battery life
reliability and of course value this
macbook has single-handedly flipped the
script in terms of the general
perception of apple macbooks compared to
windows laptops with the macbook air now
being a better value than many other
windows machines but now apple's m1 air
is finally under attack and this time
it's from the inside not only do we have
the new 14 and 16 inch apple silicon
macbook pros that are very tempting but
we're also starting to get a flood of
rumors for the next generation m2
macbook air redesign so what i'm going
to do in this review is take a look at
the m1 macbook air from a future 2022
perspective with my thoughts on how it
holds up compared to the current m1 pro
macbooks as well as its eventual m2 chip
replacement so let's jump right into it
with the m1 air now selling for only 900
on amazon there's no question that it's
still a killer value and an excellent
choice for students or anyone needing a
reliable laptop when we compared it to
other windows laptops in its price range
the macbook air always had better build
quality a much better trackpad superior
speakers higher display quality
especially in terms of reflectivity much
better battery life and almost always
better performance in various different
aspects for example it comes with a
major benefit of having very high single
core performance which gives you
incredibly impressive web browsing
performance compared to other laptops
but on the other hand it also has enough
performance to fly through many of the
common productivity tasks like music
production in logic pro programming in
xcode and video editing in whatever app
you choose and the beautiful thing about
it is that it's completely fanless which
means zero fan noise and no worries
about dust clogging up the heatsinks and
let me once again mention that no other
windows laptop can match up in terms of
battery life so for 900 on amazon the m1
air is still an absolutely incredible
value even after a full year especially
if you factor in the excellent resale
value and i would fully recommend this
macbook air over any other windows
laptop in its price range but now let's
move on to the next contender apple's
most recent 14-inch m1 pro macbook pro
while we absolutely love these new
macbook pros and we think they're game
changers in terms of the high-end laptop
market the reality is that they start at
2 000
over two times the price of the m1 air
since you still can't get any discounts
on them from amazon and the truth is
that a lot of the extra features and
benefits of those macbook pros don't
really matter that much for the common
person or student for example the new
mini led display is hands down the best
display we've ever seen in a laptop but
if you're a common user you're probably
not going to care too much about the
120hz promotion refresh rate feature and
the new mini led tech only really makes
a huge difference when editing or
viewing hdr content so if you never
watch hdr movies on your laptop you
might not even get to experience the
crazy thousand nit brightness anyway
since for regular use that display goes
down to a standard 500 nits which isn't
much brighter than 400 on the air and
because of the way the new mini led tech
works i personally have noticed blooming
or glowing issues while watching movies
like dune so the point that i'm trying
to make is that the display on the air
is still really good since it supports
true tone and p3 color accuracy and as
far as the everyday use components like
the trackpad and keyboard they're
basically the same and they both have
touch id but the downside with the new
macbook pros is that they're noticeably
larger and heavier which sucks for those
people who really prioritize portability
and because of the wedge-shaped design
of the air it's actually noticeably
thinner as well and then when we get
into performance while the new m1 pro
models were quite a bit faster the m1
air held up impressively well
considering the price point and the fact
that it outperforms the old 16 inch
intel macbook pro in many different ways
so when we're talking about the common
person who isn't going to be doing
productivity tasks all the time waiting
an extra minute to export 50 raw photos
in lightroom isn't going to be a deal
breaker especially since they're only
paying 900
instead of 2 000 and the impressive part
is that the macbook air is rated for
even better battery life than the new
macbook pros with 15 hours of web
browsing compared to just 11 on the 14
inch and it gets an extra hour of movie
playback now of course the m1 pro
macbook pro has many other benefits like
the better 1080p webcam much better
speakers thinner bezels on the display
and of course all of the extra ports
including mac save but paying an extra
eleven hundred dollars for those
features is a tough pill to swallow so
in my honest opinion if you can't take
advantage of those extra features and
the extra performance on a daily or at
least a weekly basis then spending the
extra cash simply is not going to be
worth it making the m1 macbook air the
best choice for you even though it's a
full year old already and this finally
brings us to the last contender the
upcoming redesigned m2 macbook air now
i've been seeing some comments from
people hoping that the new macbook air
is going to come as soon as the spring
of next year but that's simply not true
first of all the latest rumor from ross
young who has a 100 track record shows
that the new 27-inch imac is going to be
coming at apple's spring event so
there's no way that apple will introduce
the m2 chip alongside that new
redesigned imac so the next possible
event after that for the m2 macbook air
reveal would be apple's wwdc in june but
it also looks like that's not happening
for a couple of different reasons first
off ming choco has already reported that
the redesigned macbook air is only going
to start mass production in the third
quarter of 2022 which only begins in
july which would mean that a wwdc reveal
is not likely and since apple usually
never reveals new mac products at their
september event we probably shouldn't
expect the new m2 macbook air until
october or november so the point that
i'm trying to make is that if you choose
to wait for the new redesigned m2 models
you could be waiting almost a full year
and if you think you're going to be able
to get the new m2 model for the same
999 msrp you're probably wrong as well
when mark german first told us about the
redesigned macbook air earlier this year
he mentioned that the new one is going
to be a higher end version of the
current m1 macbook air which is expected
to remain in the company's lineup as an
entry-level offering yes that's right
when apple releases the new m2 model the
m1 macbook air is still gonna be in the
lineup kind of like how the super old
series 3 apple watch is still in the
lineup to this day and this actually
isn't the first time that apple did this
to the macbook air for example in 2018
apple released the newly redesigned
intel macbook air with the updated body
language and retina display for a
starting price of 11.99
but they actually kept the old silver
bezeled macbook air around for another
year at the entry level
999 dollar price and based on mark
german's report i think apple is going
to do exactly the same thing this time
around keeping the m1 air at the same
thousand dollar starting price while
introducing the new m2 model for 11.99
and this is actually a deal breaker for
people who don't want to spend more than
a thousand dollars on a laptop so
waiting for an even more expensive 1200
m2 air would be a mistake compared to
buying the m1 air on amazon right now
for 900
and you can find the link to that deal
down in the description or pinned
comment below but let's say you are
willing to wait almost a full year and
you're willing to spend an extra 300
what exactly are you gonna get with the
new m2 air well first of all it's gonna
take on the new flat top and bottom
design language from the m1 pro macbook
pro except that the body is gonna be
quite a bit thinner and lighter and the
awesome thing about that is that they
can easily fit in the same battery in a
thinner laptop because the current
tapered design makes it complicated to
fit in larger batteries but now with the
new flat and boxy shape there is a lot
more internal volume for batteries so we
could see even better battery life in
the new m2 air going further it's gonna
come with max safe charging which i
really really like and while it's still
expected to get only two usbc ports one
of them will likely be on the right side
of the macbook which is going to be very
convenient and it's also going to get a
wide variety of color options like we
have on the current 24 inch imac and
it'll most likely get off-white display
bezels and a matching keyboard
which some people find repulsive for
some reason but i personally really like
it the display is also going to get the
new mini led display tech but it won't
be getting the new 120 hertz pro motion
refresh rate feature and while i'm not
100 sure if it's gonna be getting a
notch or not the latest rumors point to
it getting a new 1080p webcam but other
than that not much is going to be
different except for of course the new
m2 chip in a recent video i estimated
the performance of the m2 and i ended up
with some pretty impressive performance
results with a decent boost coming to
both the single core performance and the
multi-core performance which is going to
help for productivity tasks but likely
is not going to make that big of a
difference for common stuff like web
browsing and the reason there won't be a
massive jump in cpu performance is that
the m2 chip will continue to have the
same exact cpu layout with four high
performance cores and four efficiency
cores now on the other hand the graphics
performance is gonna get a huge
improvement since we're expecting the m2
to get an extra two gpu cores so we
could see metal scores close to around
thirty thousand which is very impressive
so based on all of that if you can
stretch your budget all the way up to
around twelve hundred dollars then the
new m2 air is gonna be totally worth
spending the extra cash but if you're
limited to under a thousand dollars and
you don't really want to wait
potentially up to a full year then the
current m1 macbook air is still hands
down the best laptop you can buy right
now beating all the windows competition
while still holding up impressively well
compared to the new m1 pro macbook pro
so hopefully you enjoyed our one year
review of the m1 air and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out our new macbook
pro reviews right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]